Được là quán đúng, ra sữa đầu tiên tại Hà Nội, bán cơn vình bắt bỗ này.
Khách nước hoài đến ăn cục tấm tắc kênh ngon.
Thì mà ăn ngon mà bên chút quân, mình lę nghĩ ra nghe con cá tiết vào quà quay mình.
Hách ngon hoài là cá sữa.
Y là mình lấy cá vướng từ, vi con cá sữa đây, vẻ nấu từ.
Am ni tìm nó rất là ngon, s vèo.
Và không có vị tanh là mình đưa bà nấu từ.
Cái con cá để đi là thì mà mình bỏ vậy.
Bỏ măng bỏ, giúp bỏ đi mình đi nhoa.
Bởi vì là nó tạo nghiệm mồ trắng sữa.
Thôi mình xây nó ở ngài này nó quận vào cái bú.
Quân nhở tắc mắt mà.
Bỏ thiên vị, vị thì vào đây không.
Bỏ thiên xuân vị thì đi vào đây không.
Khách ngồi, tỏ mò, ngồi ăn nhi sao, đần đi, cảm nhận, quay ăn nhi nghe, tắc tình, quay ăn nhi.
Cần này, quay ăn.
Cần cá chiên thì mình trên mọc,
xíu không phải tầm bột mình trên tặn luôn.
Nhật được nào khi hát bật được thì mình sẽ trên lạng là ngài để cho gọi.
Bà miếng cá thì mình thấy rồi.
Bà miếng cá thì mình cũng lấy dụt tò từ một cân sấu lỗi lên.
Chả cá này nhái từ làm nhé.
Nè là từ khi tả nó.
Chúng ta có ca sức mòn nha.
Thì là cái bò của bứng cá là nó nha một bột xua.
Bình trở mò là nó xú cho dầu của ăn nhi ra bứng cá.
Bình trở là mà có em như thúc hấp 1 cá.
Chúng ta mừng hộ xay và kể kể.
Cái lực dân mà không được ra cái mồ sửa này đâu
Cái lực dân mà không hơi được quả?
Cái lực dân cảnh
Nó mặc khiến ok kế kế nước này
Nếu gồn cảnh mà lâu gồn cảnh
Cái quả có thông phải là cưới này
Cái lực dân mà không hồ chắn là cái lạy vào bèo
Bây giờ, mình sẽ bị tuyên sủyt
Bây giờ, mình sẽ sẽ trởi sủyt
Bây giờ, mình sẽ trởi sủyt